- We met Sian Jason, a
student and former prisoner,
who formed an incredible connection
while meeting once a week
to discuss literature.
Jason, we clearly saw how this
benefits the students, but
what does it do for the people in prison?
- Well, hi, everybody.
You know, in 1999,
I committed a terrible crime
and I was sentenced to 26
years to life in prison
as a result.
And at the time the like
the general attitude
about people with life sentences was that
the only way that they'd
get out was in a pine box.
And, you know, there was
a lot of hopelessness,
a lot of, you know, poor treatment
that resulted from that way of thinking,
a lot of inhumanity.
I had a lot of support from
my family and loving mother.
And I made the decision early on,
that I wasn't gonna continue
to bring pain to her life.
So I started making better decisions,
started pursuing my education
and finding other men
who wanted to do something
positive with their time.
And by the time that Palmer came in,
it was really like the
first time in almost,
I'd already been incarcerated
for almost a decade.
And Palmer started coming in
and the students gave us the first
like real encounter with
people who viewed us as people.
You know, their willingness to come in
and read books with us,
to exchange thoughts and ideas
kinda prompted us to be open
and share our vulnerabilities with them.
And along the way,
you know, we were reminded that,
"Hey, you know, our lives mattered"
and that there were
people in the community
who actually cared
- Such a beautiful
thing this program, wow.
- Yeah, and by the way,
Jason, I've become quite
good friends with Jason.
I mean, he's probably
the most educated person,
or one of the most educated people I know.
He has two master's degrees,
- Wow!
- That he got in prison.
You know, just he's one example of
the incredible humanity
that exists behind bars.
I mean, this isn't,
you know, there are certainly people
who have to suffer the consequences
of the crimes that they committed.
But there are people who
again, they are incredibly remorseful
and they have committed their lives
to trying to help other people.
And Jason, now that he's been out
I mean, he truly has dedicated his life
to trying to help people
who are incarcerated
and people who have gotten out of prison
and to try and help reform
the criminal justice system.
- Man, you have any thoughts on this?
- I mean, I'm just,
I'm humbled and in awe
this program is amazing,
And Jason
you know, I respect that you
took responsibility for your actions,
but, you can hear it in your voice,
you can see it in your demeanor,
how you evolved.
A lot of people don't know this
but my father ran with the
Black Panthers in the 60s.
And he got himself into some trouble.
And he ended up doing
four years in San Quentin.
And that's where he had time to think,
make decisions, reform himself.
And he came out a different person.
Not perfect, but seeking basic goodness,
seeking a better life for himself,
but then bigger than himself.
And you seem very similar, you know?
So congratulations to your second chance,
second chance and I love,
I love that you're helping the youngsters.
I love that it's bigger than yourself.
The fact that you're giving back
is huge man and so much respect to you.